all right so we go to joey's last pick
then i guess
when i when i saw when i saw joey
recommend this one
i wanted to like [ __ ] high-five the
dude man
why you can high-five me right now yeah
so joe recommended kudo you know which
is should i call it like famous or
infamous
definitely infamous yeah i i knew that
probably gant had seen it before but i
just wanted to
see what conor would say yeah that was
vile it was
[ __ ] disgusting it was abhorrent
there's not enough english language to
convey what you made me sit through
what the [ __ ] have you not into that it
is absolutely it is
absolutely it is an experience why do
these
this okay i don't know what the [ __ ] is
this whole show is right go and explain
that
so i feel like the premise is that there
is a kingdom right they've made a
kingdom where is the king
they've they've separated from the
kingdom we live in the kingdom they've
separated like
girls from guys and girls like kind of
live in this
kind of high-class posh kind of kingdom
and then there are the boys who are just
like the boys the boys who are just like
the dirtbag of the world
and it's basically the the main
mercenary leader is just [ __ ] guts
this is like he he
he's just guts right
this is the hentai adaptation of berserk
with even more rape
this this is just like if you this is
like
this is like if you take berserk remove
remove all the cool parts and you just
keep the rape yeah this is
pretty much pretty much i i i saw the
tags now i was like not gonna lie
i only chose this one purely to get a
reaction out of connor because i knew
god yeah watched it and god likes it so
so like the premise is the gir
the guys trying to invade the kingdoms
like that the girls built
yeah and of course they invade it and
it's like a fantasy
dark fantasy middle like uh so the first
episode they invade like the elves
yeah yeah they're like they invite
they're all they're all tanned
they invade the elf kingdom and there's
just like and
they just [ __ ] gang bang the [ __ ] out
of these guys
i guess for some reason okay so he he
wants to
sleep with this woman right why does he
let the orcs [ __ ] them what's up with
that
why are the orcs [ __ ] it's cause
there's orcs there's orcs there
also why are the orcs listening to this
guy like why what the
why why oh because the orcs want to get
something and then also
why do the orcs have human dicks you
notice that
i mean i mean because it's a hentai i
mean there's these no no no no
they do not have [ __ ] they have human
beings they do not have their [ __ ]
they have a giant human being no no no
i paused on one of the frames because i
had to take it like that is not a human
dick that is a [ __ ]
ox that's that's a [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
right there you know
it
the girl from that dick was just like as
wide as the woman's waist okay
let's be [ __ ] honest right because
what happens is right i i had to pause
it at one moment because i was just like
one this is disgusting
yeah first of all i had to pause many
times be like to stand up and go like
just [ __ ] light a cigarette i don't
even smoke
just light a cigarette but there was
just one scene and i remember it was
like four orcs and i paused and there
was like four orcs standing around each
other right like this
yeah and the dicks were blurred but you
could clearly see they were normal human
dicks yeah yeah yeah yeah totally
and i was like why this is so weird why
why okay why wouldn't have orcs dick
shaped they should have gross
ugly orchids man i mean but no one wants
to see that
does anyone want to see this anyway what
are you saying
ugly bastard with an extra faction no
that's that's
that's [ __ ] orcs they're just ugly
bastards and the dick that's like
an extra [ __ ] girthy ugly bar i
refuse to believe people like watching
orcs [ __ ] people
well then why is there so much of it why
who are these people why is that
the reason why this so much is because
there's lots of people who want to watch
it
why why would you want to watch it you
can ask me you can ask that question
about milfs
as well why would you want to watch it
no no because people are right now
are you comparing mils to ogres
are you really comparing milfs to ogus
joey
because calm down okay okay because what
i will say about kirino
is that [ __ ] it is it's
it is every [ __ ] tag that i
detest yeah this is the case let's be
honest
let's be honest are just ugly bastards
but just square with attitude yeah yeah
they're just ugly bastards for just even
uglier with a different skin tone
and like i've normally i remember first
watching cody you know and i'm just like
why
why would i [ __ ] want to watch this
but what it does
it's that this hentai is so ridiculous
and so over the top that it it just
like you know you you you know you know
that meme was not not the mean way you
know when film is so bad that it's good
no
this is that hentai for me now it is so
ridiculous
this isn't tommy white so the room of
hentai right this is so ridiculous and
so offensive
that it it's not even turn off anymore
and it just becomes hot
that that was cooler you know for me man
you think it was hot it was like i
couldn't i couldn't take this like
because you talk about you want this to
be realistic because you want to like
self-insert right
i'm like this is too ridiculous i can't
see this happening
there isn't a million there isn't a
million percent chance where i would
ever self-insert myself
anywhere what part of it were you able
to be like this is so hot that i cannot
do this
like what aspect okay i really like a i
really like elf girls and i really like
tanks
dude dark skinned elf girls dark skinned
elf dark skinned
elf girls man replace every hentai with
a dark-skinned elf and
you i will watch anything there is not
there is not enough dark-skinned elf
hentai in the world
i'm fine with that but you know what the
point where
five goblins were they i'm pretty sure
they created new holes with what they
were doing
there was because there was one the
immediate when he put his i think there
was only two wasn't there
i remember i remember the first time he
put his dick in and i'm like like
this is what was disgusting he was right
nearly it was like it was like the gift
where it was just like
a hole in like the train trying to smash
it through the hole
except it smashes the way through the
hole and i remember the first time i
watched it i was just like
yeah because because you you see the
outline of this thing
up to here yeah yeah yeah why can't i
see the outline
that is disgusting because that's the
[ __ ] horse like my jaw hit the floor
when he [ __ ] got the dick in man
and it was it wasn't just that i
remember the scene where they [ __ ]
come
and like i remember most you you see
most
most like most hentai protagonists have
like a bit of extra [ __ ] than like what
more any normal man could cut yeah these
orcs
have [ __ ] five gallons of [ __ ] saved
up
all inside of this girl well i'm just
like how can i take this seriously
at what point does it cease to become
and it becomes whipped cream
the scene that [ __ ] killed me is when
it like after all the first girl right
not
the queen but like the one of the
servants right after all it's done and
she's been suspended by
two cops like [ __ ] london bridge i'm
just like
this is so [ __ ] amazing it's so
stupid
it's so ridiculous that it's [ __ ] hot
it's a it's just like
she just gets spit roasted like
literally she's literally suspended by
two cops with two orcs
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so [ __ ] gross and vile and disgusting
i i legit like i i googled how to
[ __ ] clear my incognito history
i was like this is so [ __ ] disgusting
like i
i i'm glad i watched this like last
because like i i ruined my it ruined my
day i was like this is so vile
do you want to know something too well
episode 1 is probably the teamest
as well really yeah how episode like i
think
three is probably the most vile one if
you if you ever want to challenge
yourself to that one but uh
yeah everything about it was just gross
like i do not understand how
the exact reaction i was hoping for and
i'm so glad i think
like my penis actually inverted at some
point like i actually couldn't find it
like i was so tired okay but what if the
dark skin
elf was a milf no even more that's even
worse why would you ruin something
amazing no because okay oh my goodness
because right it's it's just i do not
want to see
four or five [ __ ] orcs gang banging
somewhat that is
[ __ ] up how can you take it seriously
take it seriously
how because what bothers me right is
that i'm watching this and i'm like
this is clearly something like they've
got an audience and i'm like that's
disgusting that some dude is like
[ __ ] me no because nothing does it for
me like that orc gangbang pawn you know
what i mean
there's someone out there who can't
masturbate unless it's gangbanging i
also love the scene where it's like
the queen gets like filled up and the
guy like pulls the dick out and just
[ __ ] gushes all out right like yeah
yeah yeah
like a [ __ ] water yeah like a
waterfall and the guy's like standing
there like yeah let it flow just like
like this this isn't this isn't a word i
would usually use to describe a sex
scene
but the sex scenes in this [ __ ]
hentai are epic
they're epic right like like normally i
don't imagine
[ __ ] like like do you know what i
imagine going on in like the background
of this
like i imagine like forces from berserk
playing as like they're getting [ __ ]
gang bang from seven different different
directions
because it's so epic they all i imagine
is like a [ __ ] like zack schneider
like
300 like slo-mo right i'm just like
super slo-mo
i just want something like that
interjected in this it's like this is
like too epic like
it is like like
oh my god it is
it is a classic for a reason and
it is
i like my vanilla hentai you know i i
like my i like my wholesome tags
but you know i hate i hate normally i
hate everything that this
kind of series represents but this
series does it so
masterfully it really does
so over the top that is just like if
we're talking about spice right like
crude oil
in cinnamon you feel great shame
after you know well you're like god i
can't find nice i never feel ashamed
jacking a hand
oh my god i'm past that point i've
reached hentai nirvana all right like i
never feel [ __ ] this gave me the same
feelings of like when you see like
pregnant porn pop up and you're like oh
oh god
no no it's not that bad no no it is it's
on that level of discussion
no way no it's it is not that pregnant
oh [ __ ] off
no i would watch kuronu over and over
again than ever you probably do you
don't need to would you you do yeah i do
okay i'll tell you why because pregnant
porn is like way too close to being
real this is so far removed from
anything that's
pretty much like level one of araguro
yeah mine
yeah because this one it's like set in a
fancy world in a fancy setting with
[ __ ] orcs and elves they've
masterfully just set
up the scenario to the point where there
is zero realism
so there is like no point in trying to
self-insert there is no point in being
like oh this could happen to me because
the scenario is just a hundred percent
fiction so anything that they do no
matter how ridiculous it is even though
it is fictional there's still nothing
about it that i'm like this is all like
there's no aspect what do you mean
there's no aspect you don't like the
dark skindells that's fine but i would
have rather have been done in a more
tasteful manner
allowing me to offer a more tasteful how
do you tastefully gangbang the dark
stuff
perhaps if we remove the gangling aspect
i can fix this i can fix this right here
listen
all right we removed the gangmang aspect
yeah the fancy aspect let's get rid of
that too
how about we make it she's like there's
nothing left how about she's a dark
skinned elf who's a mother
who has a stepson who you know isn't so
sure about this relationship
i like the girl which mother
just just just get mother's nose breast
and just [ __ ] turn her dancing there
you go
that's literally what you just described
that's a joke
like that that scene let's see what the
scene with the second elf one yeah where
like
they take they take turns just like like
coming
inside and it's like
there's never been a more accurate
representation of like me and the boys
no the guy's like minimum 10 shots each
laps let's go lads last laps
it's so funny i'm [ __ ] losing it just
just remembering what was going on